This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
6Mate English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Rob.
As well as bringing the world to a halt, the coronavirus epidemic has led to an increase in
misinformation, lies and conspiracy theories on the internet.
In an era of fake news, where even the President of the United States has accused of spreading
misinformation, could it be that we are living through a crisis in trust? What is trust?
And who should we place our trust in? These are some of the questions we'll be discussing in this
programme. And we'll be hearing from a philosopher who believes the problem is not about trust itself,
but about trustworthiness, the ability to be trusted as being honest and reliable.
And as always, we'll be learning some related vocabulary along the way.
Of course, telling lies and lacking trustworthiness is nothing new. Just think of the Trojan
horse used to trick the ancient Greeks. More recently, the American financier,
Bernie Maddoff, became infamous as the biggest swindler in history. In 2009, he was sentenced to
150 years in prison for his part in the Ponzi scam. But how much did he defraud from investors?
That's my quiz question. Was it A, 6.5 million dollars, B, 65 million dollars, or C, 65 billion dollars?
I'll say B, 65 million dollars. Okay, Rob, we'll come back to that later.
Generally speaking, trust can be described as a judgment that someone can be believed and relied
upon. When we trust each other, it makes life easier, quicker and friendlier.
Society can't function without trust. So does that mean the more trust the better?
Well, not according to philosopher Onora O'Neill, here he is speaking to David Edmunds,
presenter of the BBC World Service Programme, The Big Idea.
We have another word which is gullible. And if you simply place trust indiscriminately
without making a judgment about whether the other personal institution is trustworthy,
then just trusting to luck, as we say, is probably not a virtue.
There's a difference between trusting someone because you have good reason to believe them
and being gullible. That's easy to deceive because you trust and believe people too quickly.
If you don't judge who is trustworthy and who is not, you are trusting to luck, simply believing
or hoping that things will happen for the best. But being gullible and trusting to luck
is exactly how Bernie Madoff was able to trick so many people into giving him their money.
Their biggest mistake was to trust him indiscriminately in a way that does not show care or judgment,
usually with harmful results. So if indiscriminately trusting people is such a bad idea,
how do we avoid it? How can we tell who is trustworthy and who is not?
Here's the BBC World Services big idea presenter David Edmunds asking Onora O'Neill to give
some details. An individual or organisation is trustworthy if they can justifiably be trusted.
To be trustworthy they need three ingredients. First, honesty, people have to be able to believe
what they're told. Second, competence. Beyond honesty and competence there's a third element
to trustworthiness, reliability. That's the boring one, that's just being honest and competent
each time, so that it's not enough to be episodically honest and competent for some of the things
you claim to be able to do but not others. Philosopher Onora O'Neill identifies three
ingredients for trustworthiness. Honesty, competence and reliability.
Competence means the ability to do something well. You would trust a car mechanic to fix your broken
car engine, but you wouldn't go to them for dental work. They're not competent to remove your
tooth like a dentist is. And you wouldn't trust your dentist to fix your broken down car either.
Onora O'Neill also mentions reliability. Being trustworthy because you behave well all the time
and keep all the promises you make. It's the combination of these three being honest, competent
and reliable that makes someone truly trustworthy. And not someone like Bernie Maddoff who would run
off with your money and entire life savings. All of which brings me to my quiz question, do you
remember Rob? Yep, I do. You asked how much Bernie Maddoff stole from the American investors he
lied to and I said be $65 million. But in fact it was C$65 billion, a lot of money to give to such
an untrustworthy man. So we've been discussing whether there is a crisis of trust and asking how to
know who is trustworthy, able to be trusted as honest, competent and reliable.
Placing your trust in someone trustworthy is very different from being gullible,
easy to trick because you trust and believe people too quickly. And it can also be unhelpful to
trust things to luck, simply hope or believe that everything will work out for the best.
Both of these problems come about when people trust indiscriminately in an unsystematic way that
does not show care or judgment, usually with harmful results as Bernie Maddoff's victims found
out to their cost. But luckily there are many trustworthy people around and we can spot them
using three criteria. Honesty, in other words not lying, competence and reliability.
Competence means an ability to do something well in the correct and effective way.
And reliability means being honest and competent all the time, not just being honest sometimes
or reliable in some actions but not others. That's all for six minute English. Bye for now. Bye bye.